now how does medicine like five amino
DMT how what does it do to the ego so
the traditional psychedelics LSD even I
mean they use this new term entheogens
which means to awaken the divine within
and from the Greek and psychedelics is
to open the mind so they've done legal
tests in the last decade with EEG
machines and MRI machines looking at the
brain and what happens when you take
psychoactive substances so with LSD
psilocybin mushrooms things like that
what they've discovered is that these
substances switch off different regional
clusters of the brain called the default
mode Network right the dmn and it's not
that the substance is actually having
the expanded consciousness effect it's
that it's switching off the filters in
your brain stopping you from having the
expanded conscious in effect all the
time yeah but that spectrum of full
consciousness is always there and
sensitive people tune in to that in in
tribal societies they don't have crazy
people they had sensitives who they
trained to be in service to their
community and to be the medicine people
to bridge the realms and to speak with
the spirits on behalf of healing of the
people in our culture we medicate them
because we don't want the sensitives
because we don't want to know about that
right so that's the traditional
psychedelics but what it points to is
the fact that the brain or is a receiver
of the signal and well very fastly
learning with neuroscience and shamanic
techniques in this decade and more that
we can alter our consciousness
consciously with intention and we can
optimize and we can tune in to the
greater energetic reality that has
always been around us so typical